oh
[Applause]
well the controversy of course is what
they're shooting at a poster there
of the labour leader jeremy corbyn well
let's speak to our defense and security
correspondent aleister bunker
at sky news center alistair tell us more
well the mod who i spoke to this morning
confirmed that the
video is legitimate they say that it was
taken within the last couple of days
it is a shooting range that's in a loft
in a compound in the center of kabul in
afghanistan
the soldiers are from three para
deployed out there actually due to come
home
very soon anyway and that is where they
in that loft range where they practice
what's known as
guardian angel techniques so protecting
vips
as they move around afghanistan having
meetings so it's not unusual to have
pictures of celebrities
on the firing range but they use the
celebrities
uh as uh the people they're supposed to
be protecting
but of course in this case uh it's very
clear from that video that they were
shooting at
the image of jeremy corbyn and when it
pans out as you can see there and then
zooms in
you can see a number of bullet holes uh
in jeremy corbyn's
head there the army have released a
statement
saying we are aware of a video
circulating on social media
this behavior is totally unacceptable
and falls well below
the high standards the army expects a
full
investigation has been launched as i
said the ministry of defense this
morning saying that it is
a legitimate video uh people within the
air sources in the mod saying i mean
this is a terrible look and i think that
is an
understatement jeremy corbyn perhaps
is not the favored politician of many of
those who serve in the british military
but were you serving the british armed
forces
you have to be apolitical you serve the
government
of the day you serve queen and country
and this
is not the image that the mod nor the
army want portrayed